comment tu payais d'électricité pour ta
boulangerie avant sa flambe avant je
payais 4500 euros annuellement d'accord
annuellement alors là et donc
14000 euros
annuels forcément impossible de t'en
sortir c'est un scandale c'est moi je
veux dénoncer tous ces ministres tout
ces élus là qui font de la propagande
sur tous les médias la semaine dernière
on a vu Bruno lumière sur un média je
sais pas si je peux le citer ou pas sur
BFM qui a dit qu'il laisserait crever
personne aucune entreprise aucun
commerçant je veux dire moi j'ai envie
de le rencontrer ce ministre et de lui
dire venez avec moi chez liquidateur je
suis en liquidation judiciaire depuis
une semaine moi j'en peux plus quoi
c'est au madame Olivia Grégoire la
ministre des TPE des PME qui dit dans
l'hémicycle épuisé d'abord le le fond de
garantie qu'il y a des aides avant de
crier au scandale et qui vous en faut
encore plus mais forcément ton
portefeuille il va rester intact parce
que on a le droit à rien aucun des
boulangers on doit être 5% de la des
35000 boulangers en France qui ont le
droit des [ __ ] d'aide et puis pourquoi
avoir besoin d'aide je veux dire nous on
veut juste Bos récemment je veux dire la
vie d'un boulanger vous savez ce que
c'est Cyril c'est 80 heures semaine on a
pas de Noël pas de jour férié pas de
dimanche on a plus de sortie entre potes
on met sa vie entre parenthèses on a
plus de on voit pas les enfants grandir
on voit rien tout ça pourquoi pour se
faire assommer à la fin non moi je suis
désolé je cautionne pas ce système qui
nous a bouffé quoi mais c'est c'est
incroyable c'est c'est directement lié
aussi au prix de l'électricité que vous
fermez ah ben c'est c'était le coup de
massure en trop quoi ça on est déjà
chargé comme il y a pas donc on tient le
coup on fait des augmentations on rogne
sur les marges il y a des mois on sort
pas de salaire je veux dire 80 heures
semaine tu sais qu'il fait 80 heures
semaine et qui sort pas de salaire je
reviens savoir qui est autour de cette
table se sors pas de salaire avec 80
Rubens je suis désolé non c'est et puis
tous ces ministres tous ces élus là qui
font de la propagande sur tous les
médias moi je non moi je veux dénoncer
tout ce système quoi qui c'est des
pourris je suis désolé
vous avez fermé votre boulangerie
aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à y croire
terminé
je suis plus Bacter je suis en
dépression je pense je veux plus voir
personne c'est enfin voilà quoi c'est
tout le travail d'une vie quand même
c'est 5 ans moi je te les 50 ma vie
là-dedans c'est enfin voilà quoi c'est
j'ai l'impression d'abandonner tous mes
clients je veux dire vous serez venu
dimanche mais vous auriez vu le scandale
oui dimanche là il y a 3 jours vous
serez venu à boulanger mais vous aurez
vu mais c'est tout le monde pleurait
quoi c'était j'étais le pilier du
village quoi c'est
qu'on laisse faire ça moi je suis
scandalisé moi je suis révolté j'ai
envie de tout brûler je suis en colère
je suis
voilà vous avez fermé définitivement ah
oui je suis en liquidation judiciaire je
suis endetté c'est on en est là en
France on prône la baguette au
patrimoine de l'Unesco mais s'il te
plaît mais qu'est-ce qu'on va [ __ ]
cette baguette à l'Unesco ça avait déjà
bien longtemps qu'elle devrait y être
mais [ __ ] mais les boulangeries sont
en train de crever un petit feu et on va
mettre la baguette au patrimoine de
l'Unesco mais moi je ça me rend cinglé
c'est moi je prends ça comme de la
provoc je suis désolé on nous provoque
quoi c'est on mène un combat on devrait
même pas être en combat en France je
veux dire on est artisan on est des le
commerce préféré des français quand même
il faut savoir je veux dire on connaît
toute la vie des gens on les suit tout
au long de leur ville les naissances les
baptêmes les communions les enterrements
les gens se confient enfin c'est et on
nous laisse crever c'est c'est le cas
moi on m'a laissé crever je suis mort je
suis à terre je sais pas ce que je vais
faire de ma vie à l'heure actuelle quoi
c'est toi depuis dimanche terminé vous
vous faites quoi je m'attracais à la
paperasse parce qu'une mutilation
judiciaire c'est pas juste un claquement
de doigts comme ça c'est les banques les
usiers les juges les machins les la
comptables c'est tout ce malade c'est
on demande juste à voir faire notre
profession qu’on ameublement je veux
dire on demande pas être milliardaire
parce que ça serait je veux dire si on
serait milliardaire les boulangers mais
arrêtez de nous taxer arrêter de faire
sortir tout ça quoi c'est
moi je suis au bout du rouleau quoi
c'est je pense on dépression quoi c'est
quand il y a des responsables politiques
qui vous disent que vous avez des aides
mais ces aides ne m'en parlaient même
pas Cyril c'est quoi les aides parce que
voilà quand on dit mais il a des aides
comment tout le monde croit qu'on a des
aides parce que dans les médias ils
sortent tous les gros titres l'État et
les TPE les PME mais parmi rien du tout
rien du tout je veux dire où nous sommes
rien non moi j'ai le droit à 0 aide
alors forcément j'ai attaqué Bruno Le
Maire et Olivia Grégoire sur certains
médias donc j'ai eu le bureau de Madame
Grégoire qui m'a appelé cette semaine
pour savoir qu'est-ce qui se passait
donc j'ai l'impression d'entendre
Emmanuel Macron je vous entends je vous
écoute on est là pour vous mais arrêtez
votre pipeau moi je lui ai dit ça marche
pas votre propagande à deux balles il y
a quand même me dire que ma comptable
elle faisait mal son travail elle était
incompétente il m'a dit il m'a dit de
vive voix que j'avais droit à toutes les
aides mais j'ai le droit à 0 et je te le
dire parce que je rentre pas dans les
critères parce qu'ils prenait les
factures d'électricité 2021 l'histoire
des compteurs des kilowatt-heure il y a
il y a un nombre incalculable de
critères qu'on nous a sorti
forcément les boulangers nous on n'est
pas dedans je suis désolé alors on me
dit qu'on est que les ministres ils sont
au contact des boulangers et tout mais
c'est n'importe quoi je veux dire qu'il
y a aucun boulanger qui rentre dans ces
critères donc réveillez-vous quoi c'est
moi c'est plus mon combat maintenant je
viens ici pour dénoncer tout ça mais moi
je suis mort moi c'est fini aujourd'hui
vous allez faire quoi j'ai même pas le
droit au chômage ni rien je veux dire
donc je vais essayer de me reconstruire
déjà et après bah je sais quel âge j'ai
32 ans vous avez une famille vous êtes
oui je suis marié j'ai pas d'enfant mais
et voilà je sais pas où je vais je sais
pas où j'en sais rien donc là depuis
dimanche c'est trou noir ah je suis au
fond du trou je suis sur mon canapé je
reçois les téléphones j'envoie des
papiers je vais au rendez-vous pro mais
je vais vous voir plus personne quoi
c'est
c'est voilà on arrive là quoi c'est on a
tué bon je suis doté un petit village de
200 habitants on a tué le village il y a
pu les petites boulangers
de proximité je me suis diversifié pour
proposer les services aux anciens aux
personnes à mobilité réduite du village
j'ai eu leur livrer les bouteilles de
gaz les le pain à domicile enfin c'était
voilà les gens là j'ai l'impression de
les avoir abandonnés quoi c'est la
tristesse qui avait dimanche c'était et
j'ai eu un chat merci tous les clients
j'ai eu des mots j'ai eu des j'ai eu de
l'argent j'ai eu des dons j'ai eu des
bouteilles j'ai eu tout quoi c'est là
c'est impossible de repartir ah non mais
moi je veux même plus Cyril hein je suis
dégoûté du système moi je veux même plus
mettre un pied dans une boulangerie moi
c'est fini quoi c'est je me reconvertir
avant un boulot gagner ma vie
convenablement et plus d'emmerde plus
rien je fais des ulcères je fais des
migraines des blocages de dos je veux
dire j'ai 32 ans j'ai jamais fait ça de
ma vie non non
tous les jours on était avec ma
comptable elle a monté des dossiers des
simulations de trucs et avaient rien non
il y a rien il y avait dit ça à la
personne au téléphone
est incompétente voilà ce qu'il m'a dit
ah oui c'est dommage que j'ai pas envie
la conversation parce que je vous assure
que c'est ça et donc là terminé plus de
nouvelles non plus de nouvelles donc ça
c'est vous êtes libre à vous-même
votre travail comment votre femme
travaille oui heureusement heureusement
heureusement donc là aujourd'hui bon
allez vous êtes vous êtes à la maison
dans les papiers dans le j'essaye de
matrier à fermer cette société
correctement proprement et après moi je
veux plus rien savoir comme moi je veux
déménager je vais me casser c'est
on arrive à dégoûter moi je veux dire je
suis passionné de mon métier ça faisait
20 ans que je suis dans le métier je dis
depuis 5 ans que je suis à mon compte je
suis 80 90 heures semaine les périodes
de fait je veux dire on fait des
journées non-stop on dort presque 1h ou
deux on fait des siestes tout ça pour ça
mais allez vous faire [ __ ] quoi moi
c'est fini quand tu auras plus de
boulanger en France et ben vous irez aux
grandes surfaces bouffer du pain
dégueulasse je suis désolé on prône
l'artisanat français on met la baguette
au patrimoine de l'Unesco et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on nous enterre vivant moi on
m'a enterré vivant moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on m'a arraché mon bébé voilà c'est
si on nous rejoignez c'est le cri du
coeur de Julien boulanger qui a dû
fermer son commerce dimanche après
combien d'années de 5 ans 5 ans ça se
passait bien
on peut même pas dire que je faisais
j'ai dit à ma comptable j'aurais préféré
faire de la merde que il y a personne
qui venait chez moi et au moins ça
aurait été plus simple là je suis en
progression tous les mois tous les ans
même en clientèle il y a rien qui va pas
il y a juste ces [ __ ] de charges de
merde c'est tout c'est incroyable
donc la facture d'électricité n'est pas
le seul parce que c'est il y en a
beaucoup dans votre cas mais on est tous
dans ce cas Cyril on est tous dans ce
cas vous pouvez questionner tous les
boulangers
quelques mois après moi j'ai été moi
j'ai eu mon renouvellement de contrat en
septembre mais il y en a eu en octobre
en novembre en décembre et là il y en a
la majorité vont tous être pris en
dérange janvier ça va être une hécatombe
dans la boulangerie c'est et je pense
que d'autres métiers vont suivre aussi
mais nous on est vachement énergivore
dans les métiers là donc forcément on
est consommateur d'électricité mais
on a essayé moi j'ai licencié j'ai très
je me suis levé encore plus tôt je
faisais plus de cuisson l'après-midi on
a essayé j'ai même entendu comme mon
collègue là qui qui est investi dans des
groupes électrogènes qui ça coûte moins
cher de d'investir dans un groupe
électrogène d'avoir de l'électricité
mais on va où on est producteur
d'électricité en France ou pas moi ça me
moi je veux plus rien savoir moi c'est
fini c'est j'en voulais à qui ah au
gouvernement au gouvernement parce que
bon ben les aides c'est comme dit on
n'est pas des cassos on veut des aides
moi j'aurais peut-être pu tenir parce
que voilà on est pris à la gorge mais je
veux dire après on fait quoi janvier
février mars avril on a l'impression
qu'il y a personne qui se bat pour nous
les députés moi j'ai rencontré le député
de chez nous les le ministre Grégoire et
tout mais ils sont où ils sont où ces
gens là
nous on n'a pas le temps je veux dire
moi et 80 heures semaine je commence je
fais pour me battre encore pour toutes
ces taxes
c'est inadmissible
on en direct tous ceux qui vont regarder
se disent mais comment on peut on
arriver là les causes elles sont là
c'est bien sûr on l'a dit l'état des des
centrales et puis à la guerre en Ukraine
là il a pas caché ici la dépouille
aussi voilà nous boulanger forcément à
cause de l'énergie et à plein de métiers
on a au moins qui est avec nous aussi
vous avez une entreprise vous avez reçu
des nouveaux tarifs EDF pour 2023 on
demande des prévisionnels mais ils
savent pas nous répondre de quel ordre
sera l'augmentation vous pour vous la
perte elle va être énorme
bah nous on travaille le plexi le
plexiglas donc pendant la crise
sanitaire les fournisseurs de plexiglas
sont vendu des tonnes donc il a augmenté
de l'ordre de 50%
l'électricité comme je viens de le dire
on n'a pas de prévisionnel on ne sait
pas je suis assez proche de ma
commerciale qui justement qui travaille
dans ce si c'est une grosse entreprise
qui fabrique le plexiglas eux c'est fois
7 c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont passés de
85000 € à 610 mille euros
s'en sortir e c'est des grosses
entreprises donc ils ont voilà il y a du
il y a du monde ils ont quand même les
reins un peu plus solides que les
petites PME ou les petites entreprises
comme Monsieur
toute la trésorerie dans le Nouvel An
c'est un appel au gouvernement on sait
donner de l'argent à des pays qui en ont
besoin comme Ukraine voilà c'est le je
vais prendre le sujet le grand débat le
grand débat pourquoi pas annuler les PJ
des petites entreprises
pour pourquoi pas le faire
on sait le faire on sait on sait on sait
mettre de l'argent on s'est vu
William Saurin voilà ce que je dis
encore là et garb mettre la
quasi-totalité de leur production à
l'arrêt aujourd'hui ça leur coûte plus
d'argent d'ouvrir de rester fermés donc
vous rendez des multin des des grosses
marques comme ça donc imaginons
imaginez-vous quand on passe de 5000 € à
13000 t'imagines quand on fait tu fais
ton bilan en début d'année tu décasme je
vais devoir vendre tant de baguettes et
tu as 10000 € de plus sur l'année tu es
parti
on a du boulot mais c'est ça nous on a
le cas de commande qui est à craquer on
ne peut pas empêcher embaucher parce que
les charges sont trop conséquentes
on s'est serpent qui se mord la queue la
queue pardon c'est à dire que moi je
suis obligé de demander un message de
faire des heures sup de bosser le samedi
on pose dans les magasins des fois le
dimanche soir donc tout ça ça a un coût
mais il faudrait qu'on a tous les petits
commerçants
nous ma société on est passé de 20000
à 60000 x 3 donc c'est voilà alors voilà
on est on se plaint pas je vous le dis
moi mais pour vous dire voilà c'est le
ratio pour tout le monde c'est x 3 mais
quand on est une petite un petit
commerce voilà moi je pense à tous les
petits commerces là en ce moment comment
ils font comment ils vont faire
là-dessus
il y a pas un truc à trouver si les gens
nous ont aussi des gens nous regardent
sachez que j'aimerais bien voilà qu'on
est peut-être le porte-parole du
gouvernement assez vite qui viennent
nous voir voilà parce qu'en plus voilà
ça se passe bien avec lui voilà
j'aimerais bien qu'il vienne nous voir
parce qu'il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions très très vite pour ces gens
peut-être qu'à un moment il faut voir
pour dire et ben on va voir on va on va
trouver des solutions pour que il y en a
qui essayent de on va on va rembourser
les entreprises encore actuellement qui
sont encore en vie et qui survivent bien
moi c'est de mettre l'accent l'accent
là-dessus on est en train de rembourser
le PSG c'est ça vous voyez vous
comprenez peut-être non il est peut-être
là la solution c'est que peut-être qu'il
faut là c'est le coup de grâce et là moi
quand je vois vraiment je vois Julien
Julien il me faut le cœur je suis désolé
excusez-moi mais attention
de ce que tu faisais il faut travailler
fort tu avais trouvé des solutions pour
gagner bien ta vie ça a augmenté tous
les ans et aujourd'hui tu te retrouves
dans la merde alors
je sais et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
bien sûr la guerre en Ukraine c'est ça
nous ça nous peine tous mais ça c'est
une des conséquences directes de la
guerre en Ukraine on est vraiment c'est
ce que je vous avais dit là il y a
quelques mois j'avais dit on est de la
les Ukrainiens il y a pas de souci on va
pas les laisser en galère mais ça faut
avoir les moyens d'aider la guerre en
France tout le monde l'avait dit non ça
n'a rien à voir avec l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte que
ça à voir parce qu'on a fermé nos
centrales donc on a fait plaisir à des
écolos qui se mettent à genoux de
boulevard Saint-Germain-des-Prés et on
se rend compte aujourd'hui que c'est la
guerre en Ukraine et on se rend compte
que ces mecs là qui remboursent leur PGE
on leur met la double lame parce qu'on
leur dit l'électricité c'est 4 à 5 fois
plus cher et ça va arriver aussi sur les
particuliers et le gouvernement est
complètement paumé parce que ça veut
soutenir des guerres partout dans le
monde mais nous en attendant ici moi je
veux bien soutenir les guerres partout
dans le monde mais on a nos mecs là qui
crèvent de faim bien sûr aujourd'hui ils
vont licencier des mecs parce qu'ils
vont fermer il y aura 8 10 mecs qui vont
se retrouver au chômage qu'on paiera au
chômage parce que là c'est les
boulangers mais il y a pas que les
boulangers tous les métiers qui bossent
avec l'électricité une phrase qui est
très bonne on va voir les moyens ça
coûte cher la guerre ça coûte cher de
Géraldine toi qui est
d'accord avec moi non mais en fait je
suis à la fois d'accord et pas d'accord
je pense que ça ça coûte cher de
soutenir une guerre mais il faudrait
pouvoir et soutenir la guerre et vous
soutenir à chaque fois c'est comme ça
non mais tu crois que si on soutient pas
la guerre en Ukraine et si tu penses que
Poutine prend l'Ukraine est-ce que tu
penses que pour le coup ça va aller
beaucoup mieux c'est pas ça que je te
dis je te dis juste que les autres moi
tous les gens me disent c'est pas
l'Ukraine mais les autres années il fait
froid en janvier il fait froid février
les autres années il a fait froid
pendant des années il a fait froid
pourquoi c'est cette année pourquoi
comme par hasard c'est cette année qu'on
a des des électricité qui augmente x 4 x
x 6
mais il y a aussi un problème avec les
particuliers aujourd'hui il y a les deux
et Édouard Leclerc vous avez vu ce qu'il
a dit il a dit à tsunami en janvier plus
30 % partout comment déjà commencer
et en plus toi on t'a augmenté tu peux
pas comment tu fais tu es mort
Julien
que chez nous qui ont flambé le sucre
levure le sel voilà
bien sûr et l'électricité on peut pas
c'est un consommable vendre la baguette
4-5 euros on va où on a on est désolé on
espère qu'on va pouvoir avoir des
réponses assez vite parce que là il y a
vraiment d'urgence
tous les consommateurs c'est
catastrophique ce qui se passe et le cas
de Julien
c'est un cas qui n'est pas isolé il y a
une boulangerie à 40 km de chez moi elle
a fermé le même jour que moi mais
maintenant rendez-vous compte